Всіх вітаю!
Мене звати Артур Борисович і сьогодні ми
з вами будемо вивчати історію у 9 класах.
Це історія України,
Твоєї рідної Батьківщини,
Наша гордість налічує віки,
Київська Русь! Козаки!
Мазепа, Хмельницький, Нестор,
Володимир, Кий, Хорив, Щек і Либідь,
і з ними Михайло Грушевський
Перелік безмежний!
Це наша Історія - незалежної!
Будемо говорити про історію
України і темою нашого заняття буде:
«Суспільно-політичне життя
на Західноукраїнських землях
у період 60-80-х рр. ХIХ сторіччя».
Але для того, щоб ви краще
зрозуміли про що ми будемо говорити,
прошу подивитись на цю фотографію.
Ми будемо з вами говорити в
першу чергу про тих українців,
які в цей час активно намагались
боротись за українскьку ідею, за те, щоб
українці могли вільно друкувати книжки і
твори, щоб українці могли навчатись,
в тому числі українською мовою, отримувати
не тільки базову освіту, але й вищу.
Ми з вами будемо говорити про тих людей,
яких, звісно, зараз вже в живих немає.
Нас із ними розділяє ціла
прірва - це більш ніж сто років.
Але саме завдяки діяльності
цих людей, ті речі,
які зараз здаються буденними,
власне зараз і існують.
Це такі речі, як: вільне
розповсюдження і вживання
української мови, наука,
яка є на українській мові.
Нажаль, більше ніж сто років тому
ці питання ще були досить болісними
і за них треба було боротись.
І власне про цю боротьбу
ми з вами і будемо говорити.
Що це за фотографія і хто ці люди я
розповім протягом сьогоднішнього заняття.
Ну, що ж, почали!
Хочу спочатку з вами поговорити
про те, які ж саме території
ми з вами маємо на увазі, коли
говоримо про західноукраїнські землі.
Уважно подивіться на
цю карту і зверніть увагу
на території, позначені зеленим кольором.
Власне, це була основа території Галичини.
Але, знову ж таки, Закарпаття
також входило в ці землі.
Дуже важливо розуміти, що на цих
територіях існували свої суперечності
і існували певні проблеми.
Спочатку я вам розповім
про ці суперечності і проблеми.
Давайте пригадаємо, до складу
якої країни входили ці території?
Я думаю, ви згадали, що ці території
були в складі Австро-Угорської імперії.
До цієї території Австро-Угорщина
приєдналась ще у кінці 18-го століття.
Тоді ця імперія була просто Австрійською.
І ці території були приєднані в
результаті трьох поділів Польщі.
Однак, була одна дуже суттєва проблема:
територія Галичини, яку ви зараз
бачите позначену зеленим кольором.
Однак, одразу скажу, що зеленим
кольором позначена і територія Буковини,
але нас зараз цікавить
такий регіон як Галичина.
Ця територія мала одну особливість:
Галичина поділялась на Східну і Західну.
Це умовний поділ, але
нам дуже важливо зрозуміти,
що на Східній Галичині
більшу перевагу мали українці,
а на території Західної Галичини
більшу перевагу мали поляки.
Центром Східної Галичини
було місто Львів,
а центром Західної Галичини -
місто Краків.
Однак, Австро-Угорська влада
на ці особливості не звертала уваги
та дуже великі привілеї надавала
саме польському населенню.
Тому, однією з найважливіших проблем
для наших територій було доказати,
що саме українці мають переважні права
особливо на території Східної Галичини.
Ця боротьба тривала з початку
19-го століття, коли ці території
увійшли до складу Австрійської
імперії, а потім вже і Австро-Угорської.
Власне, для того, щоб боротись,
українці створили декілька організацій.
Нажаль, ці організації ідеологічно
відрізнялися одна від одної,
однак, ці організації мали за мету
якраз вибороти певні права для себе.
І почнемо ми говорити про першу
організацію - це "москвофіли".
Але перед тим, як я вам
розкажу про їхню діяльність
і про діяльність іншої організації,
будь ласка, якщо у вас є під
рукою, візьміть зошит з історії України
і, бажано, ручку або олівець.
Я вам рекомендую
намалювати ось цю таблицю.
увага на дошку
Чому? Тому що у цій таблиці
якраз є "москвофіли" і "народовці".
Вони вели між собою певну боротьбу.
У них були різні ідеології, різні методи.
Ці дві організації представляли
переважно українці
на території західноукраїнських земель.
Але для того, щоб ми їх могли порівняти,
подивитися їхні спільні і відмінні риси,
Я вам рекомендую протягом нашого
заняття заповнювати цю таблицю,
намалювавши її у вашому зошиті.
Також вам самостійно треба
буде визначити критерії порівняння.
Я вам свідомо не буду їх вказувати,
щоб ви спробували самостійно визначити -
за якими критеріями можна їх порівняти,
і потім записувати ці порівняння.
Єдине можу вам підказати, що
критерії можуть бути наступними:
ідеологія, газети, які вони
друкували, чи інші види діяльності,
якими вони займались.
Ну, що ж, почнемо з москвофілів.
Москвофіли були одними
з перших, хто зрозумів,
що Австрійська імперія не
дуже хоче допомагати українцям.
Це відбулось після
завершення революції в Австрії.
Вона, нагадаю, почалась у 1848 році.
І протягом цієї революції, і,
взагалі, в кінці цієї революції,
Австрійська влада набагато більше
привілеїв і прав надала саме полякам.
До прикладу: польський намісник
був керівником Галицького регіону,
окрім цього, полякам надавали
більше місць в австрійському парламенті.
Та і взагалі у поляків був більший
досвід цієї парламентської боротьби.
Тому, зрозумівши, що австрійська влада
надає більше преференцій саме полякам,
українці вирішили шукати
собі певний орієнтир,
який міг би допомогти
їм у боротьбі з поляками.
Таким орієнтиром стала саме Москва.
Велика кількість українців
на той час вважали,
що саме з Москвою треба об’єднуватись,
тому що Москва була православною.
Плюс до цього спільність мови
також відігравала роль і, окрім цього,
на деяких українців справило
враження, що саме московські війська
в часи революції в Австрії прийшли
придушувати повстання людей.
Тобто цей крок показав що, нібито,
російська влада сильніша, ніж австрійська
і тому можна, заручившись
підтримкою саме російської влади,
здобути собі права і преференції.
Також частина москвофілів вважала,
що авторитет австрійського
імператора починає поступово падати.
Оскільки Австрія вже після
революції програла кілька воєн -
це війна в 1859 році з П’ємонтом,
була війна ще в 1866 році з Німеччиною.
Ці дві війни були для Австрії провальними.
І тоді москвофіли, власне, зрозуміли,
що можливо настав якраз той час,
коли за допомогою Москви можна
буде відстояти певні свої інтереси.
Звісно, ця думка була досить
хибною, але, тим не менш,
вона, особливо в період 60-70-х років,
ця стратегія, ця ідея змогла згуртувати
певну частину українців.
Москвофіли розгорнули
дуже широку діяльність.
Вони заснували "Руську
Раду", це були 70-ті роки,
Це щось на кшталт політичної організації,
яка повинна була гуртувати
москвофілів і цю течію.
Окрім цього, вони собі, як деякі кажуть,
захопили дім у Львові
та зробили його таким, на кшталт
штабу, і розгорнули там діяльність.
В дім москвофілів почали приїжджати
різні російські ідеологи, пропагандисти,
наприклад, ідеолог Погодін,
який був автором концепції
так званого "руського миру".
Власне, він намагався активно допомагати
москвофілам, у тому числі і фінансово.
До речі, якраз основний
ресурс зі своєї діяльності
москвофіли і отримували з Петербургу,
тобто з території Російської імперії.
Австрійська влада на цей момент
дуже довгий час не звертала уваги.
Потім звернула. Я розповім, коли.
Також москвофіли вирішили
створити свою унікальну мову.
Ця мова дійсно буда
унікальною та досить цікавою.
Це щось на кшталт штучної мови симбіозу
російської, української і польської мов.
І приклад тексту на мові москвофілів
ви можете зараз прочитати.
До речі, ця мова називалась "язичіє".
Одразу вам скажу, що ця мова
майже не читабельна, та тим не менш,
деякі москвофіли досить активно
опонували цю мову, що навіть писали вірші.
Одним з таких авторів віршів на цій
мові "язичіє" був відомий москвофіл
з території Закарпаття
- це Олексій Духнович.
Він досить активно виступав за
ці ідеї щодо об’єднання з Москвою.
Він був письменником, писав вірші
і, власне, зокрема вірші на цій мові.
Але, одразу вам скажу,
що ця мова не прижилась.
І, я думаю, що прочитавши цей уривок, ви
можете зрозуміти - чому вона не прижилась.
Одним з найактивніших учасників
москвофільського руху був Яків Головацький
Зараз вас прошу пригадати хто такий
Яків Головацький і членом якої організації
до вступу в москвофільській рух він був.
Нагадаю, що ви вже вивчали цю особистість,
тому прошу пригадати хто це був.
І запам’ятайте, до речі,
що він був москвофілом,
тому що потім в нас буде
невеличке порівняння.
Москвофіли дуже активно діяли в період
70-80-х років, об’єднували населення,
пропагували ідеї об’єднання
з російським народом.
Вони казали, що всі слов’янські
народи від Карпат до Уралу
повинні бути у складі однієї держави.
Але дійсно, це твердження
потім було визнано помилковим.
І більш того, нарешті, австрійська
влада звернула увагу на таку діяльність
і почала звинувачувати
деяких москвофілів у шпигунстві.
Навіть відбувся судовий процес у
1882 році, у якому деяких москвофілів
намагалися звинувачувати в тому, що
вони ведуть певну розвідницьку діяльність
на користь Російської імперії.
Більшу кількість москвофілів
виправдали, але частину засудили.
І, загалом, цей процес став негативним
індикатором, який відвернув
від москвофілів велику кількість людей,
оскільки вже в цей час, в 80-ті роки
широкого розмаху набула інша течія,
яка була орієнтована
більше на українську культуру.
І ця течія називається "народовці".
Народовці, на відміну від москвофілів,
навпаки намагались довести,
що українці для того, щоб вибороти
свої права, вибороти свої інтереси,
не повинні оглядатись на Росію чи
на Австрію, чи на будь-які інші країни.
Українці повинні
об’єднуватись і тільки гуртом,
шляхом об’єднання всього
українського населення Західної України,
Наддніпрянщини, можна буде
нарешті вибороти свої права
і створити свою власну,
в ідеалі, навіть державу.
Ці погляди про державність
вони виникли трохи пізніше,
вже під час формування політичних партій.
Про це ви дізнаєтесь також трошки згодом.
І, власне, народовці орієнтувались
тільки на українську культуру.
Вони читали твори багатьох
українських письменників
в порівнянні з тими ж москвофілами.
Для москвофілів ідеалом
була російська література
і місцева література,
написана на "язичіє".
Також вони були, скажімо
так, натхненниками
російського культурного світу.
В той же час, народовці
навпаки орієнтувалися повністю
на українських письменників, зокрема і на
Тараса Григоровича Шевченка, і на інших.
Шевченко звичайно був ідеалом в той час.
Тому, відповідно, народовці відстоювали
українську течію і, що дуже важливо,
саме діяльність москвофілів
мотивувала народовців діяти активніше,
оскільки українська патріотична
молодь, представники інтелігенції,
представники такого молодого
духовенства, вони побачили конкурентів.
Вони зрозуміли, що якщо вони не будуть
рухатись, якщо вони не будуть діяти,
то оцей проросійський
рух - він зможе домінувати.
Тому, відповідно, і народовці, що
виникли в кінці 60-х початку 70-х років і,
власне, почали активно діяти.
Про їхню діяльність якраз і поговоримо.
Що ж вони створили?
По-перше: вони заснували організацію,
яка називалась "Руська бесіда".
І тут одразу бачимо один
схожий момент з народовцями:
у москвофілів була "Руська рада",
а у народовців "Руська бесіда".
"Руська бесіда" також відігравала роль
культурно-розважального товариства.
«Руська бесіда» збирала навколо себе
представників української інтелігенції,
також навколо цієї організації
виник український театр.
"Руська бесіда" була утворена
якраз в 60-х роках 19 століття.
Давайте ми з вами
проаналізуємо один уривок.
Це спогади Олександра Барвінського.
Що ж він говорив?
увага на екран
Звісно, можливо трошки
незвичний формат цієї цитати,
але якщо казати простою мовою,
«Руська бесіда» мотивувала народ
цікавитись українскьою культурою,
залучала до створення цієї культури.
І ви бачите, що і міщанство, і селянство
- в них зросла національна свідомість
завдяки існуванню цієї
організації та її бурхливій діяльності.
Звісно, для того щоб поширювати свої ідеї,
треба було створити друковані органи.
З 70х років 19-го століття народовці почали
активно займатись видавничою діяльністю.
Вони засновували багато різних видань.
Одні з основних - це були газета "Правда",
літературно-науковий журнал народовців,
ви якраз бачите невелику
частину цього журналу,
і також політичний часопис
народовців, який називався "Діло".
Що цікаво: у москвофілів також
був часопис, він називався "Слово",
а народовці створили
часопис який називався "Діло".
І, знову ж таки, що ми бачимо - це
протиставлення цих двох організацій
і їхня певна конкуренція. Зауважу,
що ця конкуренція була мирною.
Це дуже важливо.
До якихось насильницьких
дій в цьому протистоянні
не вдавались ні народовці, ні москвофіли.
Також народовці друкували і інші
газети, зокрема журнал "Вечорниці".
І, що цікаво, одним із
редакторів цього журналу
був син Маркіяна Шашкевича
- Володимир Шашкевич.
І тут також є одна особливість
цього протистояння.
Пам’ятаєте, я вам казав, що одним
із прихильників москвофільства
був Яків Головацький?
А тепер пригадайте, що об’єднує Якова
Головацького і Маркіяна Шашкевича.
Я думаю ви пригадали.
Це їхня спільна діяльність у
такої організації як "Руська трійця".
Вони були союзниками. "Руська трійця" мала
на меті розвивати якраз українську мову.
Але що ми бачимо тут?
Ми бачимо тут, що погляди розділились:
Яків Головацький перейшов на
позицію москвофільського руху,
а вже син Маркіяна Шашкевича перейшов
на позиції українофільського руху.
Знову ж таки, можна зробити певний
висновок, що ось це протистояння -
воно певною мірою розділяло
людей, але це був об’єктивний шлях,
оскільки українці на той момент
шукали куди рухатись і як розвиватись.
І не було єдиної ідеї.
Але варто сказати, що завдяки бурхливій
і завдяки активній діяльності народовців,
саме українофільський рух, особливо
з 80-х років, почав бути домінуючим.
І це дуже важливо.
Однією з дуже поширених
організацій, що створили народовці,
була організація під назвою "Просвіта".
Про неї зараз поговоримо
трошки докладніше.
"Просвіта" виникла у 1868 році.
Одним з членів-засновників цієї
організації був Юліан Романчук.
Дуже відома постать, займався
і письменницькою діяльністю,
і, в тому числі, політичною.
Власне, яка була мета "Просвіти"?
Як казали засновники цієї організації,
вони хотіли спочатку зробити так,
щоб ідеї народовців, ідеї
української самобутності,
української свідомості дійшли
до абсолютно усіх людей.
Але проблема була в тому, що велика
кількість людей не вміла читати і писати.
Відповідно, якщо друкувати газети,
писати книжки, то для кого це буде,
якщо люди не читають та не пишуть?
Відповідно, основною метою існування
просвіти, спочатку було освідчити людей,
навчити їх читати та писати,
особливо українською мовою.
І тому, якраз "Просвіта", як організація
і члени цієї організації
відкривають клуби, читальні.
Вони створюють необхідні умови
для того, щоб селяни навчились читати
і щоб до них дійшли ідеї
української свідомості.
Власне, дуже важливим
було те, що "Просвіта"
на початку свого існування вступила в
певну боротьбу якраз з москвофілами.
І дуже довгий час засновникам
цієї організації - народовцям
надавали можливість розгорнути
таку широку діяльність.
Боротьба йшла дуже довгий
час, але вже в кінці 70-х років
"Просвіта" розгорнула
дуже широку діяльність.
Відкривались клуби, філіали "Просвіти" по
всій території західноукраїнських земель.
Тому "Просвіта" стала одним з
таких найпопулярніших органів,
який поширював українську
культуру, вчив людей читати, писати,
розповсюджував українську культуру
по всім західноукраїнським землям.
Вже у 20-му столітті
філіали "Просвіти" виникли
навіть на території Наддніпрянщини, але
про це ми будемо говорити трошки пізніше.
Окрім "Просвіти", також
дуже важливим було утворення
і літературного товариства
імені Тараса Шевченка.
Ініціаторами утворення цього
товариства, знову ж таки, були народовці.
Воно виникло в 1873 році.
Основна мета цього товариства це
допомога україніским письменникам
у розповсюдженні їхніх творів,
розвиток української літератури,
друк українських книжок.
Згодом це товариство було реорганізоване
і воно перетворилося в 1873 році
у наукове товариство
імені Тараса Шевченка.
Ініціатором створення як
літературного товариства,
так і реорганізації,
був Конинський.
Наукове товариство повинно було
об’єднати як фахових науковців,
так і науковців-аматорів.
Воно займалось розвитком науки,
воно робило дуже велику ставку,
великий акцент на дослідження історії.
І це наукове товариство складалося
з трьох основних факультетів.
Вони, власне, займались якраз філологічною
сферою (розвитком мови), також займалися
сферою історичною (історико-філософською),
і природничо-математичною.
Це наукове товариство дуже
активну діяльність розгорнуло
в період з 1897 по 1913 роки
і продовжило діяти потім.
Ця активна діяльність пов’язана з
іменем відомого українського історика
Михайла Сергійовича Грушевського.
Ви напевно вже про нього знаєте,
але я вам трошки розкажу про
його таку початкову діяльність.
Родина Грушевського
жила на території міста Холм.
Нагадаю вам, що це досить
давнє українське місто.
Його заснував ще князь Данило Галицький.
Місто Холм було столицею
Галицько-Волинської держави певний час.
Потім з міста Холм родина Грушевських
переїхала на територію Кавказу.
Жила у Владикавказі, в місті Тифліс.
І саме там Грушевський поступово почав
долучатися до вивчення української історії.
Його надихали книжки багатьох українських
істориків, зокрема це і Пантелеймон Куліш.
Гадаю, ви пам’ятаєте, що він написав
чудовий історичний роман "Чорна рада".
Також його надихали і інші історики,
такі як, наприклад, Микола Костомаров,
який присвятив свої праці козацькій
діяльності і Богдану Хмельницькому,
і Івану Виговському, писав
також про Івана Мазепу.
Окрім цього, на Грушевського дуже
сильно вплинули і малоросійські пісні.
Їх, нагадаю, записав або уклав в збірку
відомий український етнограф М.Максимович.
Власне, надихнувшись українською
історією, Грушевський присвятив своє життя
подальшому дослідженню
української історії і українським подіям.
Грушевський згодом навчався в
університеті святого Володимира,
але умови діяльності на території
Наддніпрянської України були мінімальними,
оскільки Росія прийняла
дуже жорсткі закони.
Зокрема - Емський указ, який забороняв
писати українською мовою,
який намагався знищити все, що пов’язане
з розвитком української культури.
Тому велика кількість української
інтелігенції та науковців переїжджають
на територію саме
західноукраїнських земель.
І, до речі, одним з наслідків
Емського указу є те,
що бурхливе наукове і культурне
життя перемістилось більше
з Наддніпрянської України на
територію західноукраїнських земель.
Власне, якраз в 90-ті роки 19-го століття
Грушевський переїжджає до Львова.
Там йому запропонували
очолити кафедру історії України.
Вона називалась трошки
інакше та зміст її був таким.
Вивчалася, в тому
числі, і історія України.
До речі, запропонував Грушевському
цю посаду Володимир Антонович,
оскільки власне Антонович
повинен був очолити цю кафедру,
але на той момент він був
вже достатньо старий і розумів,
що він вже напевно не "потягне" цю справу,
тому й запропонував це Грушевському.
І Грушевський у віці 28-ми років
став одним з наймолодших професорів,
який очолив цю кафедру.
Це відбулось у 1894 році.
Грушевський відрізнявся своєю
величезною енергією та працездатністю.
Переїхавши на територію
західноукраїнських земель
і почавши там займатися
науковою діяльністю,
він долучився до участі у науковому
товаристві імені Тараса Шевченка
та згодом йому запропонували його очолити.
Саме в той період, коли
він очолював товариство,
почали друкувати різноманітні збірники
та часописи. Друк став дійсно регулярним.
І, завдяки діяльності Грушевського,
ця видавнича справа навіть
почала приносити прибуток.
Нарешті газети, журнали стали
купувати - це стало прибутковим.
Навіть зараз друкована преса
не завжди приносить прибуток,
що вже казати про той час.
Але Грушевському і його
сподвижникам це вдалось.
І, власне, це було одна
з його великих заслуг.
Окрім Грушевського, велику
діяльність розгорнув ще Іван Франко.
Він займався більш філологічним напрямом.
Зверніть увагу на екран! Це та фотографія,
яку ви бачили на початку нашого заняття.
Це колективне фото діячів
наукового товариства імені Шевченка.
Якраз по центру ви бачите двох
людей, про яких ми сьогодні говорили.
Це Грушевський та Іван Франко.
Окрім цього, на цих фотографіях
дуже багато відомих людей.
Але, нажаль, за браком часу
ми не можемо про них говорити,
хоча про деяких поговоримо
на наступних заняттях.
Однак, кожен із цих учасників
НТШ поступово, потрошки
але робив дуже велику справу.
І, саме завдяки їхній діяльності,
українська культура, українська наука
отримала можливість
для розвитку і для того,
щоб вона стала доступною
для всіх українців.
На цьому у нас з вами все.
Я всім щиро дякую за те, що
ви переглянули наш з вами урок.
Не перемикайте, оскільки ми з вами повинні
повторити і закріпити те, що ми пройшли.
Тому зараз пройдемо декілька тестів.
Якщо готові - давайте розпочнемо!
Перше питання, увага на екран.
Я вам дякую за те що переглянули
наш урок і за те що відповіли на тести,
але я вам ще хочу порекомендувати
подумати над двома питаннями.
Питання номер один: чому стало можливим
протистояння москвофілів і народовців?
Подумайте, чому взагалі виникли ці дві
течії? Чому не виникли тільки народовці?
Подумайте над причиною
виникнення саме цих двох напрямків.
Друге питання:
Михайло Сергійович Грушевський
територію західноукраїнських земель
у кінці 19-го століття назвав
українським П’ємонтом.
Чому він порівнював
західноукраїнські землі
з українським П’ємонтом
і саме з П’ємонтом?
І, власне, які були причини цього?
Дякую вам дуже за увагу! З вами
був вчитель історії Артур Борисович.
До наступних зустрічей!